[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen zum sport rapport
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers mein name ist und reaktionär
ich bin selbst herr dass sportler und
heute im sportbad zu gast
paralympics-sieger zugführer weiter
april herzlich willkommen
hallo ich habe jetzt der zugführer
gesagt du bist behindertensportler als
paralympics sieger und im vergleich zu
anderen behinderten sportler für die die
uns jetzt nicht sehen sondern uns nur
hören sitzt du nicht im sportanzug hier
sondern in uniform wie geht das
es ist eigentlich ganz leicht erklärt
ich habe von oberösterreichische
militärkommando eine uniform trage
erlaubnis bekommen er ist der einzige
rollstuhlfahrer in österreich der das
ehrt mich natürlich sehr
aber das beruht natürlich schon auf
meine frühere vergangenheit beim
bundesheer ist auf mein erstes leben von
afrika eigentlich so und wenn sie doch
gleich ein bisschen ausholen darf denkt
den bezug zum österreichischen
bundesheer haben eigentlich mein
großvater schon mit gegeben der erst
anfang des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
geboren 1898 hat sogar die kaiser franz
joseph zeit mitbekommen und natürlich
auch im ersten weltkrieg schon als kind
jugendlicher dort dabei gewesen und ist
mit 20 jahren waren im zweiten weltkrieg
eigentlich mit einberufen worden
und die kommen nur ganz gut leider schon
verstorben aber ich komme ganz gut an
die zeiten erinnern als wir zu hause in
unseren leuten holzhaus gemeinsamen
stunden verbraucht haben diebe auf
seinem schoß gesessen und er aus der
kriegszeit erzählt und ich haben immer
doch wenn irgendwann mal ein beitrag
dazu leisten kann
für österreich dienen zu dürfen dann
würde die sich in anspruch nehmen und
wenn er da irgendwie aus dem krieg
erzählt hat und ich glaube wir haben
einfach diese diese basics mit geben mit
gepflegt dass man eigentlich als
österreichische staatsbürger haut muss
man auch den österreichischen bundesheer
oder den österreichischen der
bevölkerung auch zurückgeben kann mit
der präsenzdienst zeit ja und und
freilich auch mein vater ist jährigen
krieg geboren und wir sollten eigentlich
dieser generation ja unseren vollsten
respekt aussprechen und gerade in diesen
schwierigen situationen thema grad
erleben auch auf diese generation
natürlich achten lebensjahr stark
geprägt worden in diese richtung und
auch sehr glücklich auch darüber dass in
wohn ständig und
bewusst erzogen worden bin habe noch
meine schulausbildung und lehrausbildung
dann die die zeit im bundesvergleich
angetreten meine grundausbildung gemacht
beim ganze kreative partner und 13 in
ried johanna prägende zeit und ich sag
immer wieder als ganz wichtig für junge
männer und junge frauen sich verdienst
der beim bundesheer zu melden weil man
aus dem gewohnten alltag herausgerissen
wird und einfach in das system rein rein
kommt wo man einfacher viele sachen
lernt fürs leben also das ist einfach
auch die pflichtbewusstsein die
kameradschaft oder man weiss ja für was
das österreichische bundesheer steht und
es sollte unbedingt jeder österreicher
mitmachen aber dass er nicht nur die
grundausbildung gemacht also in die
fußstapfen seines großvaters und deines
vaters dann auch getreten sondern bis
dann auch für das bundesheer im einsatz
gewesen ist auch auslandseinsätze
gemacht erzählen mal von dieser zeit und
diesen erfahrungen ist es war dann auch
was ja prägen derzeit klar hinter
grundwehrdienst zeit finanziell unter
die nase gehalten bekommen das für die
vereinten nationen im speedskating
solcher häuser des friedens soldat und
das wird ein zettel gelegen habe gesagt
okay so will jetzt dabei sein weil eben
wie man der großvater des vom krieg
erzählt hat und was sie durchgemacht
haben aber doch einen kleinen beitrag
zum weltfrieden leisten kann dann werde
es sicher morgen und und genau da war
der moment ich hab dann eben diese
körperliche ausbildung macht dazu diese
tests gemacht und sie haben ein kurzes
angenommen ich habe dann noch nach
zypern fliegen dürfen und in der
pufferzone für bisschen frieden sorgen
können also wir wollen im nordteil des
der insel stationiert und wenn ich doch
nur kurze anekdote erzählt der oft ist
auf dieser zeit weil mit durch es doch
sehr geprägt hat
es war nicht nur friedliche zeiten
sondern es gibt demnach gerade in zypern
auch so jahrestage werden dort gefeiert
wo er nur teil einer süden einige sein
territorium mitgenommen hat und und
diese jahrestagen werden gehen jedes
jahr mit mit demonstrationen wieder
zelebriert kann man sagen alle fälle war
ziemlich intensive demonstration damals
und wir haben heute in der pufferzone
diese menschenkette gebildet vom süden
sind leider einige demonstraten
durchgebrochen
unser unsere finger hinter uns haben es
leider auch nicht erwischt weil
natürlich mit voller kampfausrüstung
splitterschutzwesten helm und so dass
man natürlich nicht so flexibel wie wie
ein turnschuh und soll slider
demonstrant geschafft da auf der
nördlichen seite auf einen fahnenmasten
und wolltet wird die fahne herunter
holen
patriotisch und einfach und als
widerstand und dann habe ich sehen wie
scharfschützen diesen menschen von
dieser fahnenstange runter geschossen
haben und das war ungefähr zehn meter
hinter mir und und dann hört man den
leblosen körper auf dem asphalt aufprall
und es ist also dieses geräusch ist sehr
tief in bei unter bewusstsein eingeprägt
ihre war sehr prägend im moment darum
ist und ja es hat mir wirklich für
meinen weiteren blickwinkel weiter
eröffnet also nicht nur dass man in
dieser zeit auch weltoffener worden ist
weil man einfach andere völker andere
kulturen andere religionen andere rassen
kennenlernen dürfen hat im
auslandseinsatz sondern eben weil
einfach gemerkt oh ich hab es erst
einmal an menschen sterben sehen durch
schusswaffen vorgesorgt und das hat mir
wirklich sehr geprägt da muss man dazu
sagen dass es kein österreichischer
scharfschütze war sondern weil ich kenne
mich jetzt nicht also ich kann mir gut
vorstellen dass das von anderen seite
geschossen würde also vielleicht kannst
du das noch kurz erklären und das war
kein österreicher scharfschütze sondern
jemand der dem demonstranten schaden
wollte erzählt noch genauer natürlich
ein verfeindeter wir haben wir dort
keinen kampfauftrag österreich ist ja
nicht nur wir sind jetzt seit
mittlerweile sind nicht mehr in super
nova an dieser stelle möchte natürlich
auch alle die im dienst des
österreichischen bundesheer im ausland
unterwegs seien sei das kosovo oder
georgien oder ganz egal
in afrika
einen herzlichen gruß ein herzliches
danke ausrichten weil er sehr wertvoller
beitrag für die österreichische
neutralität den für die pflicht da dass
man im internet welt der unser beitrag
leisten für unfrieden und wie gesagt
österreich wird dort kein kampf da auf
sondern wir wir soll versuchen
verfeindeten gruppierungen voneinander
fernzuhalten und david lässt leider dort
zypriotische scharfschütze der dann
einen griechischen zivilisten dort von
der fahnenstange heruntergeschossen oder
ist es ja sehr trauriger moment
eigentlich für mich und es war sehr
gefährlicher moment war udo kollege aus
england der so ungefähr was in den 15
meter neben mir gestanden zum beispiel
sind schusswechsel auch reingekommen und
er wurde auch von unseren sanitäter und
dann dort vor ort abtransportiert mit
hubschrauber ins krankenhaus geflogen
also es war auch für uns nicht so
ungefährlich und als sie abregnen
derzeit und gesagt er vollsten respekt
vor diesen menschen die sich nach wie
vor für das österreichische bundesheer
im ausland der einen dienst versehen
dienste machen
also ich habe vorstellen dass du dort
unglaubliche dinge erlebt hast die dich
auch geprägt haben als deine bundesheer
zeit also vor allem auslandseinsatz zeit
dann vorbei war
also dann deine ausbildung im
berufsleben gemacht und dann bist du zu
dem moment gekommen der sich sozusagen
in den sport gebracht hat erzählt von
seinem unfall und was genau passiert ist
du sitzt er im rollstuhl das eine
querschnittlähmung für die die sich
jetzt nicht sehen die uns nur zu hören
wie ist das genau passiert also genau
bin noch hier müssen noch mit den
auslandseinsätzen wieder zurück nach
österreich kommen meinen erlernten
zivilberuf wieder aufgenommen
in deutschland heraus geholt weil die
bienen im viertel aus rheinbach bei
schärding und ganz nahe an der grenze
auf der anderen seite ist es ihm zu
arbeiten begonnen
ja und dann war einfach unaufmerksamer
moment sorgen routine auch im job wenig
absicherung auf der auf der baustelle
wir haben das privathaus dachstuhl
gemacht und ja es war ein verregneter
tag ist es war nass keine absicherung
selber zu unvorsichtig
und dann bist du dem leben passiert und
alle menschen seien dort nicht gefeit
davor jeder werden davon darum steigen
aber man weiß ja wenn man aufmerksam
durchs leben gehen oder vereine sekunde
auf die andere kann das leben einfach
hin wie anders ausschauen und bei mir
war's eben diese arbeitsform von den
bedrohungen am tag ausgerutscht oder
gestolpert über die dachkante
heruntergefahren so dreieinhalb meter
und kopfüber eben mitten im flug so
gedreht wie er katze heute irgendwie
reagiert und bin aber leider dann zum
glück auch im rücken gefallen hat man
dort einen zehnten elften brustwirbel
gebrochen und und das rückenmark so
stark verletzt
ja die erstversorgung hätte nicht besser
oder schlechter machen hab mir gelagert
den hubschrauber bin dann nach
regensburg geflogen waren in die uni
klinik dort operativ versorgt
zur stabilisation system eingebaut
worden und wieder narkose munter worden
bin
der oberarzt kommt zu mir der mit
operiert hat gesagt der haut garnituren
wir haben einen großen freiraum gerät
der blinker hat man das erklärt was
passiert ist wie wohl seit gemacht hat
und und zum schluss sei dann noch gesagt
ja das rückenmark ist zerfetzt
sie werden nie wieder aus dem rollstuhl
heraus kommen also irgendwie hält anfang
habe ich natürlich lockt okay
schulmediziner der hat es gelernt er hat
das super gemacht haben super versorgt
ich war der meinung wenn man sie
irgendwie einen finger geschnitten hat
dann einfach abgetrennt habe dann ist es
wieder irgendwie zusammen gewachsen
mache zwar vielleicht der visual basic
es gefühlt dabei oder so eingeschlafen
ist gefühlt aber es ist zumindest wieder
zusammengewachsen und immer am anfang
der meinung auch im rückenmark auch in
der wirbelsäule wird es auch so sein
also die nerven während die sich
irgendwann einmal verbinden und die
werte vielleicht dann doch wieder
irgendwann einmal mehr zumindest der
fortschritt der machen können
aber dem war leider nicht so und so
schwierige situation weil natürlich auch
meine frau da zu diesem zeitpunkt
dritten mal schwanger war
wir haben ein kleines haus kaufte und
viele schulen korb durch das ist ja und
dann lebe ich mit einer eigenen
einstellungen einer eigenen behinderung
und ihre und habe einfach so viele
fragen kommen und keine antworten auf
diese fragen und wie hast du dann im
endeffekt vor allem in der situation in
der familie
für dich lösungen gefunden für dich
antworten auf diese fragen dann gefunden
als er der erste kleine strohhalm der
mega biesel aus diesem tief heraus
geholt hat weil es war nicht nur der
körperliche schmerzen extremer metalle
schmerz eigentlich im kopf hat es
richtig weh getan hat da das ungeborene
kind und wirkt okay wir haben jetzt die
aufgabe werden jetzt eltern haben wir
sollten eigentlich uns nicht auf
irgendwelche negativen sorgen im leben
konzentrieren sondern eben wir haben wir
aufgabe vor uns und es war eigentlich
die erste kleine strohhalm im dezember
ist dann sozusagen unser tochter gesund
geboren
ja und dann einfach das soziale umfeld
der frau war damals zu diesem zeitpunkt
25 jahre jungs mädels eigentlich mich
hier von anfang an gesagt okay wir
keinen steinen weg legen will einfach
nur ich weiß jetzt selber nicht wir
leben mit behinderung ist und ich will
einfach nur ja ist ja gesagt einfach wir
versuchen es gemeinsam nach wie vor
seiner heirat geht mir genauso wie vor
noch ganz gut und die familie danner der
freundeskreis dass man wieder den alltag
integriert wird dass man weder
vernünftige arbeit und daneben auch
wieder in weiterer folge das
österreichische bundesheer und ebner
sporthilfe paralympische komitee
behindertensportverband es gibt so viele
leute im hintergrund der mir die liga
eigentlich nur im handball concours
bilder besser aber ich muss mir betreuen
die was mich unterstützen die was mir
helfen meine sponsoren der drc store vom
trainer zum beispiel ganz einen großen
beitrag geleistet dazu dass ich
eigentlich durch in die weltspitze
gekommen bin und das mit office trinken
ihre fitness training aber mental
trainer hubert physiotherapeut natürlich
anraten kann immer die arbeiten nicht
nur für walter ablinger aber es sie
geben ihr bestes und sie merken okay von
walter ablinger kommt diese energie
zurück und der will das wissen wie man
sie immer die leistung steigert und wie
man vielleicht in tokio oder nächstes
jahr wieder mitmachen
ok und dann dann macht jeder in seinem
gebet in seinem fachgebiet wirklich
schulungen fortbildungen sohn okay jetzt
sommer wie kann man das jetzt bei im
behindertensport nur professioneller
aufziehen
damit man wirklich in tokio am podium
stehen also ganz viele menschen die zu
einer leistung beitragen aber wie bist
du dann direkt in den sport gekommen
nach dem unfall
wie du schon angesprochen hast das ganze
umfeld war unterstützend aber es war
sicher emotional auch nicht einfach wir
bitten den sport hinein gekommen
in ihrem großen ganzen hat man nur zwei
möglichkeiten in dieser situation
entweder man inzwischen wie sie ist ob
auch das beste draus oder man scheiterte
eben daran und die bin jung sofort merkt
der fr ok ich muss versuchen meine rest
funktionen im körper bestmöglich zu
nutzen damit sie auch den alltag häufig
gut bewältigen kann
und jetzt hat man dort begonnen mit
rehabilitationssport wenn anfang
versucht man über 15 meter stufe hoch zu
kommen und dann steigert sich das ganze
geht ist beginnt man fragen wie ihr
kleines baby eigentlich das leben neu zu
leben
man lernt wie man sie ansieht man lernt
wie man von petrausch kommt man lernt
wie man ins auto rein kommt wie man
mobil wird man lernt einfach ja das
leben neu grund von grund auf neu und
sport ist die extreme stütze eigentlich
in dieser phase und ich hab dann
wirklich alles ausgelotet ich habe
wirklich alles versucht was man im
rutschen nur versuchen kann war von
wakeboard von übergriff spielen von
alpinen ski fahren da war zum beispiel
auch im b nationalkader dann hat der
trainer gesagt hat oder meine frau
angesagt ist loosli aber das wird nichts
mit dem rollstuhl basketball weil er
doch im fußball eigentlich groß geworden
bin und wo ich da wieder mannschafts
sportart suchen was ist das da gibt es
so viele möglichkeiten triathlon
schwimmen auch oder eben auch im
handwerk von und dieses handwerk von
morgen dann eigentlich seit mittlerweile
zwölf jahren professionell seit 12 nach
peking hauptmann der dfb-trainer
begonnen an trainingsplan zu schreiben
und strukturiertes training aufzubauen
ich habe noch irgendwo verbraucht damit
die ungefähr um ein bisserl mit folgen
keiner hat mit dem it top athleten in
österreich und hoffe dann schaut merkt
okay es komme mal ungefähr mit jetzt
kommt noch ein bisschen mit es war
prozess einfach steigerungs prozess habe
dann irgendwann österreichische
staatsmeister mit von keiner
irgendwann bin ich ein protest von der
europacup rennen starten ob nun 2011 die
erste wm medaille doch keiner 2012 ein
riesengroßer erfolg in london wo es
vielleicht sogar für mieter und ein
bisschen überraschend war aber dann ein
jahr später weltweit der mittlerweile
habe jetzt dreimal weltcup gesamt
weltcup gewonnen den 14-fachen
staatsmeister und haben eigentlich dort
in der weltspitze mit meinem team hinter
festsetzen können also alles dominiert
alles gewonnen in den letzten jahren im
handbike foto das jetzt angesprochen
dass viele sportarten gemacht was sicher
wichtig war für die rehabilitation
warum ist dann genau dem handbike hängen
geblieben war das dass der erfolg war
das eine faszination fürs fürs kurbeln
im handbike also das handbike fälle die
uns jetzt nicht sehen und auch die
bilder nicht im hintergrund sehen liegt
man ja sozusagen ein in einem fahrrad
mit händen am rücken und zwar ziemlich
tief also was hat dich so fasziniert an
dieser sportart dass du beim handwerken
geblieben ist ja grundsätzlich wo es
eigentlich hier die geschwindigkeit also
mal kommt darauf an geschwindigkeit und
auf straßen wo man sonst im rutschen
längen hinter gekommen war und intuition
aber es war einfach liefern zum beispiel
hobby stunde meint das nächste skigebiet
kopfhörer oder zum basketball eineinhalb
stunden nach linz zum beispiel zum
nächsten basketball rutschte
basketballverein aber und deshalb von
zuhause aus machen können und es habe
einfach strukturiert täglich aufbauen
können und ich bin einfach von dieser
geschwindigkeit von dieser wie man die
eigene muskelkraft auf die straßen
übertragen so und und ihr haben wir
vorher mittlerweile als ein marathon
bestzeit auf die 42 kilometer ist ja 58
minuten und 50 sekunden also jeder
ambitionierte sportliche radfahrer weiß
wie man eintreten muss weil man im
schnitt 43 km h fahren will
also da muss man natürlich immer wieder
herunter bremsen und wieder neue
beschleunigen 1900 und du machst das nur
aus den armen das heißt da eine
gewaltige ausdauerleistung aus deiner
ober und unterarme ist natürlich mal
versucht das so gut wie möglich zu
trainieren ist klar ich habe mal kehrte
weiß nicht ob das jetzt der biologische
richtig ist aber in der
oberschenkelmuskulatur um zwei drittel
mehr mehr volumen an oberarm des wagens
auf die 43 km h vom schnitt darauf
rechnet dann müssten eigentlich ja sagen
wir die tour de france wie gut das ist
wieder andere geschichte weil dies ja
berge geht oder so aber sonst müsste es
eigentlich hier sagen immer zwei drittel
rechnet 120 km/h vor hannover das
glauben sich anita umlegen es ist aber
es zeigt auf jeden fall welche gewaltige
leistung oder im handbike auch
produziert du hast jetzt die paralympics
auch schon angesprochen auch die sind
verschoben worden und findet hoffentlich
jetzt wie geplant statt du hast
paralympics von gewonnen da ist auch
schon mehrere
medaillen kannst du als ziel auch etwas
formulieren für den nächsten paralympics
oder gehst du es einfach an und schaust
hier ist kommt wie du die form hast dich
an du bist super form du hast doch 2020
die wenigen rennen die es gab gewonnen
also ist es schon auf jeden fall ein
gutes indiz oder er ist ein guter weg
passt optimal weise fühle mich sehr wohl
so hohem alter eigentlich mittlerweile
auf einer zeiten hat sich schon ein
bisschen weder das haupt gesagt wann ist
weil ich jetzt bin ich schon
fortgeschrittenen alter und ja mal spürt
schon jedes jahr also das ist nicht die
regeneration seite wird immer länger und
und diese spritzigkeit fehlte bislang
das ziel für das heurige für die heurige
saison ist natürlich ja die ersten mal
die qualifikation wieder zu schaffen wir
sind noch nicht fix qualifiziert wir
haben in österreich aktuell drei
quotenplätze für ihren behinderten
radsport bei den männern sind ganz knapp
vor dem vierten platz also das heißt wir
müssen die ersten weltcup-rennen jetzt
anfang mai in ostende und in der toskana
wirklich gut punkten noch und die
qualifikationszeit bei uns im
behinderten radsport für tokio heuer
geht bis anfang juni da haben die
weltmeisterschaft in portugal
das heißt wir müssen dort nun
anschreiben damit man immer an den
vierten startplatz dazu bekommen werde
dann tatsächlich besetzt also schaut
jetzt mal ganz gut aus das jedoch
vielleicht dabei bin aber sein der sich
fünf sechs leute die da diese vier
startplätze in anspruch nehmen wollen
aber auf jeden fall bist du immer für
eine medaille gut das weiß man von dir
neben dem sport ist aber auch sehr aktiv
für menschen mit behinderung für
inklusion in unserer gesellschaft warum
ist das so wichtig dass du dich da so
engagiert dass er doch zeit die dir dann
wahrscheinlich woanders fehlt also warum
machst du das
trotzdem glaube das ist evolution zur
leidenschaft worden ich hab das ist ein
bisserl zum hobby wollen für mich und
ich glaube meine mit meinen worten oder
mit meinen taten irgendwie anderen
menschen unterstützen kann
ich sage immer wieder will mir
eigentlich nicht das vorbild aufdrängen
aber wenn jemand das gut findet was der
walter ablinger macht zum beispiel oder
meine mit meinen worten in irgend einer
sitzung und einer besprechung die
möglichkeit ob menschen mit
beeinträchtigung zu vertreten
also dann werde das sich zu 100 prozent
nutzen und und vielleicht eben jemand
anderen damit unterstützen und helfen
kann
aus einer schwierigen situation
herauskommen und die immer 100 prozent
bewusst und das betrifft nicht nur
menschen beeinträchtigen sondern quer
durch ganz österreich mal mit mir leben
gerade letztes jahr das 20 20 jahre war
es ja prägend für uns alle
schwierige zeiten und ob das jetzt
privat
das problem ist mit scheidungen mit mit
finanzielles problem oder ob das im job
problem ist mit dem chef oder ganz egal
wo es bei mir ist einfach eine
körperliche einschränkung aber ob das
gesundheitlich ist oder todesfall in der
familie ganz egal wo er jedes wird in
sein leben irgendwann mit einer
schwierigen situation heraus gefordert
und ich will einfach dass vermittlung
dass trotz dieser schwierigen situation
immer möglichkeit gibt an sich zu
glauben die möglichkeiten bestmöglich zu
nutzen und wieder nach vorne zu blicken
und gesagt da auch diese pandemie
jetzt können wir hoffentlich mit einem
stoffbeutel unter kontrolle und man kann
nur appellieren die positiven seiten
dieser pandemie zu sehen weil einfach
ist wichtig ist ja dass man merken ob
nissan jetzt wieder weiter
zusammengerückt
für meinen nächsten auch verantwortlich
nicht nur für mich selber für meinen
eigenen körper sondern für die gesamte
gesellschaft wir haben alle eine
verantwortung gegenüber der gesamten
gesellschaft und wir sollen ja eben auch
testen gehen wir uns eben auch im plus
müssen eben auch weiter was getragen wie
es soll eben auch regelungen und
vorgaben einhalten und damit auch alle
aufeinander achtgeben mittlerweile hast
du schon drei töchter ich habe sie auch
in den letzten jahren immer wieder bei
wettkämpfen paralympics kennenlernen
dürfen wenn sie dich sehen und das was
du erreicht hast und geschafft hast du
sie kennen dich ja auch nur im rollstuhl
mit welchen gefühlen sollen sollen deine
züchter auf dein erreichte zurückblicken
ich bin ganz froh dass sie sehr es
gesichertes soziales umfeld mit meinen
töchtern
sie geben einfach wieder kraft und heute
meine frau den rücken frei sonst könnte
die ist ein professionell sport zu
betreiben
also natürlich neben diesen förderungen
vom bundesheer london
auch das private umfeld ist doch ganz
extrem wichtig ich will meinen töchtern
einfach nur mit geben dass wir in einer
gesellschaft leben die die trotzdem
sozial sein sollte
es ist in einem kindergarten start
prophezeit worden dass sie
wahrscheinlich irgendwo in die soziale
richtung aber irgendwann
ihr leben ausrichten weil es einfach mit
der papa zu hause im rollstuhl sitzt
so sieht ist vielleicht nicht anders
gewohnt sind ist ob schon aufstehen
rollstuhl und wenn er da drinsteht
ordnung haben sie immer ganz erschreckt
weil sie sehen am vater eigentlich ganz
selten stehen und es dann so momente im
leben sagt okay jetzt her
ihr müsst genauso nicht nur vielleicht
selber sondern eben auch auf andere
menschen rücksicht nehmen wir leben ihr
leben im paradies sagt immer wieder wir
sollten realistisch bleiben und wissen
genau dass wir alles haben beim monster
kühlschrank schauen wenn man genau
unsere kleiderschränke schauen ist ein
überfall zum beispiel oder wie wir haben
ein warmes wasser wir wir können täglich
wir uns ernähren es gibt so viele
menschen auf der welt diese ist leider
nicht genießen können und wir sollten
realistisch bleiben und und merken okay
wir leben in einer gut funktionierenden
regierungssystem und wir schimpfen und
jammer natürlich sehr gerne aber jeder
von uns hat trotzdem pflichten und wir
sollten diesen pflichten nachgehen und
immer wieder bewusst werden wie gut dass
wir uns eigentlich geht da sind sich
auch die erfahrungen die du bei deinen
auslandseinsätzen gemacht hast die dich
da geprägt haben und natürlich auch
durch den unfall und den sport hat da
jetzt auch einen appell gerichtet wo
jeder von uns auf jeden fall etwas
mitnehmen kann und uns auch ein bisschen
die orientierung in die zukunft anders
gestalten kann wenn du noch einen kurzen
tipp für die zukunft der menschen geben
kannst auf basis seiner erfahrungen auf
basis eines erlebten wie man in
herausfordernden zeiten wirklich gut
durchkommt einfach das klingt jetzt
vielleicht blöd etwas was einen putsch
seien motiviert aber du hast sicher
genug auf lager von diesen dingen auf
basis von dem was du alles erlebt hast
was würde das seien eben mal wieder
unser gehirn arbeitet er mit synapsen
und umso öfter dass wir positive
gedanken in diesen in diesem
gedankenfluss hereinbringt umso leichter
umso einfacher wird vielleicht das leben
sein
es ist mir dann immer wieder vor
herausforderungen gestellt aber mein
appell ist einfach wirklich das positive
das gute im leben zu sehen und nicht
immer ständige haben uns so dann ich
schaue nicht auf das was ich nicht kann
weil ich bin ständig auf hilfe
angewiesen in dieser situation
überrascht
aber auf das konzentrieren ich weiß
genau wo sie vielleicht noch leisten
kann wo sie für österreich auch noch
beitragen kann zum beispiel wenn ich mir
jetzt obst metalle in tokio heuer wird
kann es nicht versprechen aber wer
zumindest mein bestes geben und er wird
versuchen österreichs bestmöglichst zu
vertreten und auch das bundesheer
bestmöglich zu vertreten weil einfach
sie geht man soziale sicherheit sie
gehen einfach diesen rückhalt denn ich
brauche und wie gesagt alle menschen da
draußen sollen sie vielleicht wirklich
einmal auf sich selber ein guter tipp
wer immer das immer so stellen sie
stellt sich um einen akt vor dem großen
spiegel hin
man muss sieht man mal sieht den
menschen der nackten menschen in den
spiegel und man sieht eigentlich nur das
äußerliche man sieht eigentlich nur okay
du bist vielleicht erhalten
vielleicht ist ja ganz locker und
rutschte vor damit große ohren aber es
ist nur das äußerliche dies ist nur die
schale ist versucht es mal wirklich in
diesen menschen rein zu schauen muss man
den menschen wirklich aus sr leiteten
menschen wussten was was kann der mensch
besonders gut zum beispiel zu hören
keine ahnung oder eben einen anderen
helfen oder ist sozialer vielleicht
angesagt darunter jeder ganz andere
zugänge gesagt wirklich einmal schauen
muss wie ran muss an wirklich selber
weiterbringt und wo ist ein wirklich
selber als mensch ausmacht und damit auf
das positive konzentrieren damit auch
schaffen etwas zurückzugeben das so wie
du viel zurückgegeben hast du nicht nur
sportliche erfolge sondern auch viele
leistungen abseits des sportes
herzlichen dank für deinen besuch beim
sport report danke für deine gedanken
für deine erlebnisse und alles gute
natürlich auch für tokio und für seine
weitere zukunft weiter aber danke dir
danke andreas wir sie in unserem podium
in tokio ich werde alles dafür geben
damit dort wieder gemeinsam medaillen
gewinnen können
danke auch an alle die zugehört und
zugeschaut haben beim sport report und
ich freue mich euch auch nächstes mal
wieder begrüßen zu dürfen
[Applaus]